[Music]
in wrong exit news Oh No
submitted by Chad vans since 2011
Chad pan since 2011 was he a fan of Chad
or is it Chad that's been a fan or he's
just a Chad fan yeah exactly as I'm
saying a fan of chat I think thanks for
your fandom a man who was impaled
through his groin on a fence sparked a
fight between his friends what odd while
he was impaled uh I don't know
while he was there I don't understand
yeah I gotta hear that story I didn't
know what the hell is happening that
math did not work in my head hmm using
paled by a fence his groin was impaled
on the fence of correct he's trying to
climb over the fence my brain started
filling the gaps right now what exactly
is like went through yeah okay yeah so
the sort of fence kicked his balls
yeah either he was going over the fence
and it got impaled okay just [ __ ] one
of my friends fingers got impaled while
climbing a fence in fifth grade he got
to the top and then somehow I got stuck
when he jumped off a trip though oh no
what a dumbass dude Mike Mike my friend
could pee like six feet piece if that
was his thing he can pee like six feet
can you stop thinking about other guys
it sticks for just a second was big guy
looking about his pee stream just the
stream you know what okay we had moved
on he started wave form so there's this
one guy at the party that he was
apparently way too rowdy that everyone
was telling them hey he needs to leave
and so instead of taking the stairs this
man just jumped out of the window
what on the fence sounds like a badass
okay this guy was done this [ __ ] right
yeah he was so drunk that he didn't even
scream he didn't even try lifting him up
damn I'm out of the fence
you didn't even react at all like he was
so [ __ ] up or his eyes open
what was he thinking dude this is like
right before sunrise so like a all-night
thing
drew cuz I'm hitting on it what's that
blue [ __ ] 150 what is it won't be 151 oh
yeah yeah so then once he was stuck on
the fence apparently like there was
these two guys that started arguing over
whose friend that was and then it
escalated even more so point where one
of these dudes shattered a bottle over
another guy's head what a party is great
that's a rager but if we could have a
zoo of dumb drunkards that would be
awesome be great I go to the zoo again
yeah yeah I'll be so you can do it go to
the zoo with dumb drunk people no cuz
they're just too much that's gorilla
glass you got glasses
you're away you're away gorilla glass
yeah we love glass yeah you're fine you
get a refreshment yeah you get your kid
their animal hot version of the person
inside see take a look at the counter
right see you always say that like you
know what the kid at the fan of gorillas
they always sound like the gorilla
Harris Mirchi this one would be the the
impaled guy on the fence a fence hat and
there's a guy bailed on it and the way
that one of my favorite things to do in
Vegas is go to the poker room at the
Caesars they have a it's like right in
the middle and that's where all the like
clubs go out and the lines and stuff so
in the middle of the night when people
are leaving it's the funniest scene
there's like girls being dragged out and
like little wheel chair things and in
like this
it's a deal have shoes on - just walk
around feels like in their hands yeah
[Applause]
that's pretty yeah like babies your ass
can't walk beyond so here's some photos
where this took place
what a lovely landed that's all but on
the right side is that inhaler on the
floor nope probably was head wrap
because we got the bottle he's the one
that broke the bottle and why are you
squinting dammit there everyone's drunk
and look like hungover does this friend
the bottle what was it a frat party it
was a Steven Seagal bar fight dude this
is amazing deep in single that's what it
looks like it looks like the aftermath
yeah yeah Dan that's not mend a guy that
smashed the corona bottle over the other
man's head was like I thought I was
going to kill him crazy yeah he's like
the guy didn't die was that a complaint
he was upset that he didn't I thought
that was gonna kill him that sucks you
jump out the window and you [ __ ] land
like this I read that wrong it was
actually a witness that I thought he was
going to kill him
okay that's not as funny sorry yeah I do
not miss these type of parties I've
never been to that type of party same
where everyone's drunk and stupid
well not this dude it depends on the
time so like if you're getting [ __ ] up
with everyone at the same time it's fine
but when you're sober and you walk in at
1:00 a.m. it's a different it's like
worse what the [ __ ] is it an even coat
it's like being an atheist going to
church like what is this [ __ ] right
literally yeah what does that all mean
like that's how it feels that do you
like this [ __ ] close you and then
they got the beer bro yeah I actually
like their breath there's a bunch of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] Nikki life yeah I don't
know why she doesn't like just stranger
beer breath no no no yeah well you're
like making out and then like that oh I
like breath like I like the smell of his
breath and like if it has beer in it I
like I don't know I like it get a room I
kiss mama but it screwed up okay what
part of the but all of it her butt was a
great sing like the smell of my sweat to
like like a sweat I'm a real man deliver
sweat lead to give it to you
deal-breaker for me yeah smells a
deal-breaker if it's the wrong smell
yeah very sensitive night once dated a
guy that smelled like sour milk like his
like yeah like yeah yeah but I didn't
know before like you know saying and
then we were cuddling and I'm like
smells de venise me was something to eat
then I realize like no that's just how
he smells and I think it's pheromones
like we're predetermined like what we
are biologically attracted to and who we
should mate with and if you don't like
someone sent like you're not supposed to
mate with them like someone else could
find his scent really pleasure genetics
are too similar
so that's nature telling you your baby's
gonna be all [ __ ] up it's true - he
was the only half Filipino guy I ever
dated guys okay I'm here his name was
Steve - and he was tall he was the only
other stalkers your dad would have
proved so much more people Steve okay my
dad did like him my grandma really liked
that I was dating a Filipino guy Wow
that nice man
but I thought he was boring honey yeah
sorry Steve old Steve it wasn't just to
smell it wasn't just to smell it wasn't
it no and you also like made a lot of
weird references about women like like
in general like he would blanket
statement women like he'd be like like
women should stay in the kitchen no no
like he'd be like new women you always
need to be doing this and it's like yeah
I was called radio station because they
were doing like I don't know like a
[ __ ] rat lightning hour or whatever
where callers could just come in and say
whatever they want and so I called the
radio station and I was like hey I'm
motorcyclist hits a woman whose fault is
it and then they like I don't know who
and I was like the motorcyclist what the
hell was he doing writing in the kitchen
and then every single call after that
was just people be like yo what the [ __ ]
man oh [ __ ] this dude I'm a troll that's
why the whole rest of the hours just
people calling in like hey man I thought
that was kind of funny I don't know and
then the rest of people do that
y'all [ __ ] this guy like I can't believe
this [ __ ] like I have a mother and [ __ ]
like bunch of [ __ ] that's funny
just sick dude just stick 20 years ago
or something I was like 15 you know 30
35 now I can't do it how's your math bad
when your math is so good what do you
mean because you calculate things really
well use my calculator no no what I need
to I know that [ __ ] right if I'm
calculating like some investment thing
is going to head math but I can't do I
can't do when it's lies
he can't do like if I'm like 20% it's
just 20% move the decimal point over you
can't you can't do it yeah I used to be
right there I know how you feel man okay
well you grew out of that
have you guys ever witnessed the crazy
ass injury I thought you I thought
you're gonna say I have you guys ever
seen a man jump out of a window and
appeal and that'd be dope I just say uh
no no I haven't I've only just been
trying to figure out a way to use the
pun on the fence this whole time but
there's no way to do it
there's no argument on the fence I love
him or we just like to be like someone
let you know that it was there in the
ammo we're all happy
let's put that one away maybe someone
fight so I could be like I don't know
who to go for I'm on the fence
unbelievable
no opportunity an opportunity will make
it even worse we're gonna close with
that we're gonna just yeah we're just
gonna cut
[Music]